c'est qu'on bouge pas pendant dix ans la
bouche par jean galle
j'ai attendu la fin du dernier coup
alors derniers coups de pédales c'était
quand les damnés coup vraiment pas jeté
hier
ah ouais on vous entraîner tous les
robots c'était bien ah ouais fait
combien de kilomètres par jour
oui oui des jours où je fais pas grand
fins une heure de piste c'est très
fatigant par exemple
donc quand je fais une heure de piste je
fais un entraînement soutenu et
normalement lui à près de 45 km vous oui
ou non pas tous les jours mais en gros
quoi ils pensent qu'on les met dans le
bain co va faire beaucoup plus mais bon
jouer il ya je me suis baladée deux
heures une amérique aurez quand il
débarque il a été par exemple c'est pas
les policiers lui auraient alors
dernier coup dur d'aller contrôler un
des 13 ans mais rien pour les contrôles
à dernier coup de foudre bien et coup de
foudre
votre mari il ya longtemps quand même là
mais avoue chercher
merci pas longtemps cela non non c'est
un coup de foudre de quelque chose qui
m'a plu c'est pas mal
vous pensez pas un mec en fait vous êtes
pur c'est bien dernier coup de gueule
c'est un peu râler les réputations là
moi je vous trouve charmante mais on
m'avait dit elle un peu râlé l'avenir
non dernier coup de gueule baffe au
téléphone un oui mais contre qui quand
tous ces gens qui vous répondent de
façon un personnel qui peuvent pas que
il regarde sur l'ordinateur on entend
les techniques comme ça et puis que ils
sont à trois milieux de 2,20 quoi enfin
bon c'est pas rien n'avance quoi on a
des répondeurs et puis on attend puis on
recommence en mc anglais ou conclu
quelques moyens concrets moi je suis pas
du des réservations d
cgv non mais d'attentes de caunes
dernier coup de fil l'année coup de fil
bienvenue à des rites dernier coup de
fil me souviens c'est mon neveu pour
dire que j'arrivais à paris avant ça
donne un coup de rouge dernier coup de
rouge
oui s'il n'ya pas très longtemps c'est
pas tous les jours quoi ah oui dernier
coup de rouge c'était il ya quelques
jours
ah ouais vous devez pas du vin tous les
jours non dernier coup de bluff elle a
maintenant 100 le pinard à nos derniers
coups de blues dernier coup de blues
hier pourquoi air inter à l'eau dernier
qudra oui il ya aussi lundi sexuelle des
grands forte et aussi un bond à mesure
deux bords dont j'avais précise le coup
de rein quand même mon vélo
ah c'était ça ne voudra sauver son bien
j'aurai pas répondit spontanément vienne
avant de sprinter maine d'angers sco
répondu ça c'est bien
alors avant de passer aux modalités
suivant un petit email de sylvia de bot
lane qui émeut dit la semaine dernière
vous avez refusé de faire dix secondes
de silence pour les suisses est ce que
vous seriez prêt à le faire pour les
italiennes
oui
c'est pourquoi les faits pour les
italiens mais j'aime beaucoup les
italiennes bien